foreign
of your credit score
is based on you interacting with debt
your FICO score
is not determined by you winning
financially
you could your boss could walk in today
he's not going to she's not going to and
say you now make a million dollars a
year and your FICO score will not change
one point
the phone could ring and your
grandmother could say your Rich uncle
that you didn't know you had just died
and left you 10 million dollars and your
FICO score will not change one point
your FICO score is not a sign you are
winning with money
it's a sign you have played kissy face
with the bank
it is based on the debt that you have
the debt load the type of debt the
length of time you've had the debt the
ratio of the debt to your income
how you have paid the payments on your
debt it is an I love debt score
mathematically speaking the algorithm
says that you the way to have a 700
and 50 or 810 FICO score the only way to
have that is to really really love debt
you have to keep a lot of it and you
have to pay it
it will cost you hundreds of thousands
of dollars over a decade to build a FICO
score and keep a FICO score of 800
because it's the only way that FICO
score is calculated it is not an I'm
winning with money score it's an I love
to support the bank because they're so
awesome score
in other words it's dumber than a
freaking Rock
so here's what happens
when you quit borrowing money
and you've paid off all of your debt and
you don't have a single account open
your FICO score will disappear
within about a year
as a matter of fact they will treat you
like you have moved to Mars
like you have one eye in the center of
your head
your FICO score is now undeterminable
oh
you mean you can't determine that I
haven't borrowed money
I think it just means it's zero
but it's undeterminable
it's like going to the airport it's a
terminal
I don't want to do things that are
terminal I'm going to do things that
bring me life if they say you have
terminal cancer that's not good but we
go to the airport we call it a terminal
undeterminable oh
sounds spooky the problem is so years
ago I quit borrowing money so I haven't
had a FICO score in like 30 years
um I'm not really here
I'm off the grid this is actually a
hologram I don't really exist because
according to you people I don't have a
FICO score so I'm a nobody but according
to my banker I'm a nobody with millions
of dollars in her bank
so and I still have a zero FICO score a
non-und undeterminable FICO score and
guess who just joined the club it's my
zero FICO score day
we sold our house in May took about five
and a half months and my FICO score is
zero that was your only debt yep and you
sold the house the mortgage is gone yep
you're a renter yep temporary
temporarily right now until you figure
out the housing market and what you're
going to do and uh from May to
basically end of November beginning of
December I have not had a single piece
of activity and zero accounts open of
any kind and no lates on there and no
bad debts on there obviously and uh
that's how long it took for your FICO
score to evaporate yes yes it's gone and
it's so funny the email was like
basically like oh we don't know what
happened this happens sometimes but we
can help you correct it yeah sometimes
horrible things happen to people and
we're here to help we're from FICO right
you're debt free wait what we can help
you get back in debt you haven't made
offerings to the great gods of FICO you
need to make offerings of Interest oh
great FICO you are the provider of all
good things we bring you offerings of
Interest so that we can buy anything we
want on credit later so you borrow money
why so that your FICO score is up score
goes up why so that you can borrow more
money so why because your FICO score
goes up so why so you can borrow more
money I had a dog that used to chase its
tail and he was crazy
hahaha
and this culture does it every day and
you're free I'm free man
like when you're
when you're in for it to go to this we
were talking about this about a month
ago you're going are you sure it's going
to go away I'm like I'm not sure of
anything with FICO except that when you
quit borrowing money eventually they're
going to cause you to say you don't
exist yeah I was like Dave how long how
many more weeks how many more months and
he was just like just stay the course
Christina said I think it's going to be
a year because I at that point so made
so what is it seven eight months yeah
something like that for it to go away
right five seven months seven months
yeah for it to go away before and and it
went down before that yeah it had a good
like 100.
ah
up to the 700 yeah like 700 right yeah
all right and and because you paid your
mortgage on time you paid everything on
time and then you got out of that and
then you sold the house and so you went
from 700 so you had a fabulous by all
standards FICO score and it eroded it
went down to 600s yeah
going to the 500s I mean I wasn't you
were checking out I was I was just
waiting for myself you're asking me
about it it's scaring me it's getting
low well I was just waiting for emails I
was waiting for the email that said zero
and so they sent me an email saying that
had been updated and so I was like oh
it's zero and then I went and it was
like 600 and I was like oh being in the
housing market that's kind of yeah
someday I want to buy a house and I
can't do that with a 600 when's this
thing going to go to zero Dave and I'm
like all the data that we have all the
you know all you people out there that
we work with all the stuff you send us
everything we keep up with from you guys
the research we don't know because FICO
doesn't publish their algorithms right
they don't tell us what the thing is but
just observing people have done what you
do it takes six months to a year and
yours took seven months yep
follow the path and George had a zero
FICO score went and got a mortgage with
manual underwriting with Churchill
Mortgage and so if you're gonna go get a
mortgage with Churchill Mortgage and you
have a zero credit score an
undeterminable they will write you a
mortgage and it's exactly the same rate
as if you had a seven or an 800 FICO
score
only they have to do stuff like do
manual underwriting so they have to
verify that you have money with your
bank you have to verify that you have a
job which is what they ought to freaking
be doing anyway what are you doing
giving people a loan based on one number
I'm going to loan you eight hundred
thousand dollars for a house why because
you have one number that says FICO FICO
FICO oh that's so crazy it's crazy how
our system rewards debt and people who
are it's more it's more than rewards it
I mean by God it manipulates it and
causes it people just I mean because
I've been doing this for 30 years the
amount of hate mail and hate crap I get
to this day telling people to not borrow
money and get rid of their stupid kissy
face I love debt score
is crazy I'm keeping my credit cards
open because Dave grips you didn't know
he's talking about I mean he's only got
several hundred million dollars but he
doesn't know what he's talking about
that man's dumber than a rock just
dumber than a freaking Rock